AND MACRON OF FRANCE.
>> LET'S GET REACTION FROM
SARAH CARTER.
SHE'S PRESIDENT OF THE SECURITY
STUDIES GROUP.
AND JIM HANSON AND RETIRED
COLONEL DOUGLAS McGREGOR.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE TONIGHT?
THE GOAL HERE IS TO PROVIDE A
STRONG DETERRENT OF USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
>> WELL, THIS IS A DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
SYRIAN PRESIDENT ASSAD SAID HE
FIRST LAUNCHED CHEMICAL ATTACKS
IN 2013.
I WAS TALKING TO A DOCTOR WHEN
THE ATTACK WAS LAUNCHED AND I
REMEMBER THE HORROR THEY WERE
FACING THEN.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT AS A
DETERRENT SINCE THEN.
BUT NOW WE SEE THREE NATIONS
JOINING TOGETHER, FRANCE, GREAT
BRITAIN, AND THE UNITED STATES,
SENDING A STRONG MESSAGE.
PROLIFERATION IS WHAT WE'RE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT HERE.
IF WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK, THEN
THIS IS THE REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT DID THIS.
HE WAS STANDING ON THE PRINCIPLE
THAT HE TOLD THEM, IF YOU CROSS
THIS RED LINE WITH ME, I HAVE TO
REACT.
AND EVENTUALLY HE DID.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT
AND SEE HOW THIS UNFOLDS BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT RUSSIA'S
REACTION IS GOING TO BE TO THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED.
BUT BULLIES ARE BULLIES.
BUT WE STILL DON'T KNOW.
>> WELL, I FIND THE WHOLE THING
PERPLEXING.
FIRST OF ALL, JUST A WEEK AFTER
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCES HIS
INTENTION TO WITHDRAWAL TROOPS
FROM SYRIA SUDDENLY, DECIDES TO
LAUNCH A CHEMICAL ATTACK.
SEEMS VERY ODD.
THEN WE SEE SARIN AND CHLORINE
GAS USED TOGETHER.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
THAT'S THE FIRST IN THE HISTORY
OF CHEMICAL WARFARE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
FINALLY, WE SAID, WE DIDN'T
REALLY INFORM THE RUSSIANS.
BUT WE KNOW THE GERMAN PRESS HAS
TOLD US OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS
OF CONSISTENT BACK CHANNEL
REPORTS BETWEEN WASHINGTON AND
MOSCOW.
SO I'M QUITE OBVIOUS WE MADE THE
RUSSIANS AWARE OF WHAT WAS GOING
ON AND THEY GOT OUT OF THE WAY.
AND WE PICKED TARGETS THAT IN
RETROSPECT MAY TURN OUT NOT TO
BE WHAT WE THOUGHT.
>> SOUTH SUDAN HAS HAD A
FOUR-YEAR CIVIL WAR THAT'S
KILLED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
ENTIRE VILLAGES VERY BURNED,
BOYS AND GIRLS LOCKED IN STRAW
HUTS AND LIT ON FIRE.
THERE ARE ATROCITIES COMMITTED
EVERY DAY ALL OVER THE WORLD,
INCLUDING IN CHINA.
AND YET WE GO IN AGAIN WITH A
MILITARY STRIKE A YEAR AFTER A
PREVIOUS MILITARY STRIKE.
AND I GUESS IT FEELS GOOD
BECAUSE THERE ARE HORRIBLE
THINGS HAPPENING THERE.
BUT WHAT DO WE REALLY ACCOMPLISH
HERE TONIGHT IN SYRIA?
THIS IS NOT WHY DONALD TRUMP GOT
ELECTED IN MY VIEW.
>> BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DELIVERED A WARNING AND VLADIMIR
PUTIN, ASSAD, AND THE IRANIANS
ALL IGNORED THAT WARNING.
HE DELIVERED ON THE PROMISE HE
WOULD RETALIATE.
AND IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
WE ALSO HAVE A STRATEGIC
INTEREST IN IRAN NOT BECOMING A
LAND BRIDGE TO THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
>> THAT HELPED THEM.
>> THAT'S A BIGGER STORY.
BUT WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
HERE IS HE DELIVERED THE CORRECT
MESSAGE TO THE CORRECT PARTIES.
WHAT WAS BLOWN UP, IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
THE FACT THAT WE WILL DELIVER ON
OUR PROMISES AS THE UNITED
STATES.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT THAT WE
PUT THE BAND BACK TOGETHER AND
ACTED IN CONCERT.
THAT MATTERS TO THE WORLD TO SEW
THAT WE ARE NOW A COALITION OF
SOME OF THE STRONGEST COUNTRIES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IS
HOW IRAN IS MOVING ACROSS THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> AND HOW DID THAT START?
A LOT OF DOMINOES FALLING IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
AND SOMETIMES WHAT FEELS GOOD IN
THE MOMENT, THE IRAQ WAR, WHICH
I WAS IN FAVOR OF, THEN FOUR
YEARS LATER, WHAT'S ISIS?
>> HOW WE GET OUT MATTERS.
>> YOU'RE SO SMART.
WHY DID ASSAD DECIDE TO DO THIS
NOW, SEBASTIAN, GIVEN THE FACT
THAT DONALD TRUMP -- HIS
INSTINCT IS LET'S GET THE HECK
OUT OF THERE, TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SPENT IN THE MIDDLE
EAST, CHINA IS ON THE RISE, WE
DON'T WANT TO GET BOGGED DOWN
THERE.
AND THEN THE ATTACK HAPPENS.
WHY DID THAT UNFOLD THAT WAY?
>> LAURA, I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE QUEASY TONIGHT, BUT
LOOK, COLONEL McGREGOR IS BEING
OBNOXIOUSLY OBTUSE.
THIS IS A BATTLEFIELD WHERE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ARE ON THE
LOOSE WITH MULTIPLE ACTORS, MANY
OF THEM JIHADISTS.
THIS IS A REGIME THAT HAS
COMMITTED MASS MURDER.
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS IRRELEVANT
TO AMERICA IS SO ASTRATEGIC IT
--
BUT WE HAVE TO ASSERT OUR MORAL
CLARITY.
YOU DO NOT GET TO USE ILLEGAL
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST WOMEN
AND CHILDREN.
AND I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE A
YEAR AGO AND I SAW THIS
INTELLIGENCE.
AND GUESS WHAT, COLONEL, IT WAS
THE ASSAD REGIME THAT DID IT.
AND WHEN A FOUR-STAR RETIRED
MARINE CORPS LEGEND TELLS YOU
THAT WE'VE SEEN THE INTELLIGENCE
AND IT WAS ASSAD, EVERYBODY
SHOULD TAKE THAT TO THE BANK.
AND SHAME ON YOU FOR QUESTIONING
GENERAL MATTIS RETIRED?
>> I DON'T THINK HE MEANT WHAT
HE SAID.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CLEARANCES AND YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
IT.
>> WELL, YOU WOULD SEE SURPRISE
IT HAD CLEARANCES THAT I HAVE.
WILL YOU PLEASE COME DOWN FOR A
SECOND?
>> NO, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD
BEFORE.
>> NOT WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
>> ONE AT A TIME.
SEBASTIAN, YOU CAN RESPOND IN
ONE SECOND.
>> IT WAS A MILK PRODUCTION
FACILITY.
WE'VE HAD SO MUCH
MISINFORMATION.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT CLEAR WHAT
HAPPENED A YEAR AGO.
I COMPLETELY --
>>IT IS TO ME.
YOU WERE OUTSIDE THE BUILDING.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
AND I HAVE SPENT MY LIFE IN THE
MILITARY AND I HAVE SEEN
INTELLIGENCE MANIPULATED
REPEATEDLY OVER THE LAST 25, 26
YEARS.
>> I'M GLAD YOU KNOW BETTER
THAN THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
>> I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
NEEDS TO LISTEN TO THE 50
MILLION AMERICANS WHO VOTED FOR
THEM.
THEY DID NOT VOTE FOR THIS AND
THEY DIDN'T SUPPORT THIS.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT --
>>I'M GLAD YOU SPEAK FOR ALL
AMERICANS.
THAT'S VERY MODEST OF YOU.
>> WELL, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
WAR POWERS RESOLUTION BECAUSE
THIS ALWAYS COMES UP EVERY TIME
WE LAUNCH A MILITARY STRIKE.
AND IT ALLOWS THE PRESIDENT TO
USE FORCE ON A TEMPORARY BASIS.
HE CAN DO IT ON HIS OWN, DOESN'T
HAVE TO GO TO CONGRESS, VERY
LIMITED, NARROW CRITERIA.
MANY SAY TONIGHT THAT DIDN'T
MEET THAT CRITERIA, THAT THIS
TYPE OF STRIKE ACTUALLY DOES
REQUIRE CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL.
I UNDERSTAND.
I CAN ACTUALLY MAKE THE ARGUMENT
FOR BOTH SIDES.
>> THE WAR POWERS ACT HAS NEVER
BEEN TESTED IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
SO THERE'S NO RULING.
>> THANK GOD.
THEY GET MOST STUFF WRONG, TOO.
>> IT GIVES THE PRESIDENT
AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT HE NEEDS TO
DO.
IF HE THINK IT IS SYRIAN REGIME
DROPPING CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN A
THEATER WHERE THERE ARE U.S.
TROOPS ON THE GROUND IS
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO BOMB THEM,
HE'S GOT EVERY RIGHT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO ASK ANYBODY.
>> JIM JUST BROUGHT UP A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT.
WE DO HAVE TROOPS ON THE GROUND.
WE ARE STILL CONTINUE TOGETHER
TRAIN.
PEOPLE ARE STILL LOSING THEIR
LIVES IN THIS REGION AND THEY'RE
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST NOT JUST
ASSAD BUT IRANIAN IRGC ON THE
GROUND.
WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS, WHEN WE'RE IN DIRECT
THREAT, AND NOT JUST TO OUR MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE GROUND BUT ALSO
OUR NATION.
WE HAVE TO THINK OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING A LOT OF PEOPLE AREN'T
THINKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE VARIOUS REBEL GROUPS.
>> DID ASSAD ATTACK ISIS?
>> YOU MEAN DID ASSAD ATTACK
ISIS?
I HEARD A NUMBER OF THINGS.
>> NO.
>> BUT RIGHT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, THE SYRIAN ARMY WAS
BEING PROMISED
BEING PROMISED B
BEING PROMISED BY
BEING PROMISED BY T
BEING PROMISED BY THE
BEING PROMISED BY THE O
BEING PROMISED BY THE OBA
BEING PROMISED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT'S A WILD PLACE.
LET'S FACE IT.
IRAQ WAS A WILD PLACE THAT VERY
FEW AMERICANS UNDERSTAND.
IT IS INCREDIBLY COMPLEX.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
ETHNIC AND TRIBAL CONFLICTS AND
ISIS OFFSHOOTS THAT THEY FIGHT
AMONG EACH OTHER.
SIDE.
WHY DIDN'T GERMANY JOIN US IN
THIS EFFORT TONIGHT?
THE BIGGEST ECONOMY IN THE EU,
SUCH A CRITICAL ALLY OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> THE SAME GERMANY THAT TOLD
ITS AMBASSADOR IN NATO THAT HE
IS BANNED FROM USING THE WORD
"COUNTERINSURGENCY" WHEN
DISCUSSING NATO OPERATIONS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT PAPER TIGER.
LOOK, I HAVE TO COMMENT ON WHAT
SARAH SAID.
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THINK OF ONE THING.
EVERYBODY'S OUT THERE WHO'S GOT
ISSUES, RUSSIA SAID THE BRITISH
DID THE CHEMICAL ATTACK.
DO YOU WANT TO BELIEVE THAT ONE
NEXT?
TO ANYBODY WHO HAS DOUBTS, THINK
ABOUT THIS ONE QUESTION.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE OUTSIDE
REGIME USES CHEMICAL WEAPONS, AS
SECRETARY MATTIS SAID, AND AS HE
DID LAST YEAR, AND I SAW THE
INTELLIGENCE, AND WE DO NOTHING?
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND TO
IRAN, TO ASSAD, TO PROXIES?
BECAUSE IT SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED, THAT WE
GOT AWAY WITH IT AND WE CAN DO
IT AGAIN.
AND WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO DO
IT NEXT?
IN JORDAN, ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT ALLIES IN THE REGION.
ARE THEY GOING TO DO IT IN
TEL-AVIV.
ARE WE PREPARED TO LET THAT
GENIE OUT OF THE BOTTLE?
I, AS AN AMERICAN, AS A
TAXPAYER, AS SOMEBODY WHO
BELIEVES THAT THESE KINDS OF
WEAPONS ARE ILLEGAL AND SHOULD
BE RESPONDED TO, I'M NOT
PREPARED TO PAY THAT PRICE.
>> I UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING, SEBASTIAN.
BUT MY QUESTION IS A SIMPLE ONE.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
THIS, THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY THAT.
WE'RE DOING THAT FOR
INTERNATIONAL NORMS.
IT'S THE WORST THING EVER.
KOFK
KOF
OF COURSE, IT'S HORRIFIC.
SO WHERE IS THE WORLD COMMUNITY?
IT'S GREAT THAT WE HAVE BRITAIN
AND FRANCE.
BUT WHERE THE HECK IS THE WORLD
COMMUNITY?
>> WITHOUT AMERICAN LEADERSHIP,
THERE IS NO ACTION.
>> YEAH, WE'RE OUT OF MONEY.
WE HAVE NO DOUGH.
IT'S NOT 1995 ANYMORE,
SEBASTIAN.
>> SO WE LET CHILDREN GET
GASSED.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
BUT IF WE HAVE A COUNTRY THAT IS
DESPERATELY IN DEBT AND GETTING
WEAKER AND WEAKER, AT SOME
POINT, SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY THE PIPER.
AND ABOUT TWO BLOCKS FROM HERE,
WE'VE GOT BLOCKS OF PEOPLE
LIVING OUT ON THE STREET, MANY
OF THEM ARE AMERICAN VETERANS.
>> WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH MORAL RECTITUDE?
>> I'M PLAYING DEVIL'S ADVOCATE
HERE BECAUSE AT SOME POINT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SAY, I'M NOT VOTING FOR THIS
ANYMORE THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED FOR A
WAY OUT.
HE SAID, I WANT TO LEAVE SYRIA.
WE GAVE THE PLAN TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL FOR A WAY FOR
THE REGIONAL ALLIES TO START
TAKING OUT OF THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO DO THIS.
>> DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY?
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> AND I CAN TELL YOU, TALKING
TO SOURCES IN ISRAEL AND SAUDI
ARABIA, THERE HAS BEEN A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
AND I THINK THAT SHIFT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT SAUDI
ARABIA IS MOST CONCERNED ISN'T
IS IRAN.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO MAKE
AMENDS WITH ISRAEL TO SOME
EXTENT.
>> KUSHNER HAS DONE GREAT WORK
ON THAT AND HAS GOTTEN NO
CREDIT.
>> I THINK YOUR VIEWERS SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT CONGRESS IS A
RUBBER STAMP.
IT'S NOT DOING ITS JOB AND
HASN'T FOR DECADES.
IT'S COMFORTABLE SITTING THERE
AND TURNING EVERYTHING OVER TO
THE PRESIDENT UNTIL SOMETHING
REALLY BAD HAPPENS AT WHICH TIME
THEY WILL BLAME THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS A FACADE.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO LOOK LIKE
SOMETHING.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> WHAT WE HIT ON THE GROUND
TONIGHT IS MEANINGLESS.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> WITHOUT RUSSIA, ASSAD WOULD
NOT EXIST.
WITHOUT RUSSIA --
>>ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT RUSSIAN
TROOPS AND FACILITIES?
>> YES.
IRANIAN TROOPS ARE THE CRITICAL
FACTOR IN THE VICTORY IN SYRIA.
NOW, THEY ARE GOING TO DIVIDE
THAT COUNTRY.
IT'S OVER.
>> SO RUSSIA AND IRAN ARE GOING
TO DIVIDE AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> BUT I ALSO THINK WE WERE
STRATEGIC IN HOW WE DID THIS.
IF WE  TARGET IRAN SPECIFICALLY
--
>>SEBASTIAN, LAST WORD.
>> JUST LISTEN TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
HE SAID VERY CLEARLY, WE ARE NOT
THERE TO DO SOME KIND OF
INTERVENTION LIKE IN THE GULF
WAR BACK IN 2003.
WE ARE THERE TO MAKE A STAND
AGAINST ONE OF THE MOST HEINOUS
FORMS OF WEAPONS KNOWN TO MAN
THAT ARE ILLEGAL?
IF WE DO NOTHING, THEN AMERICA
AS A NATION STARTS TO LOSE ITS
MEANING FOR WHAT IT REPRESENTS.
I KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN WHAT THAT
NATION REPRESENTS.
YOU'RE A BELIEVER.
YOU BELIEVE IN THE ETERNAL
VALUES THAT OUR FOUNDING FATHERS
INSTILLED IN THOSE FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS.
IF IT MEANS ANYTHING TODAY, WE
TAKE THIS ACTION.
>> I THINK WE COULD ALL PULL
OUT QUOTES.
>> IT'S NOT FUNNY.
>> BUT, SEBASTIAN, DON'T GET ON
YOUR MORAL HIGH HORSE WITH ME.
DON'T PLAY THAT GAME WITH ME
TONIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT A JOKE.
>> YOU'RE RAISING THE FLAG OF
THE FRAMERS.
I CAN QUOTE WHERE THEY'RE
WARNING US ABOUT GET AMERICA
ENTANGLED IN FOREIGN AFFAIRS
OVER WHICH WE CAN HAVE LITTLE